coronavirus tanks the stock market Joe
Biden seeks a big comeback victory and
perhaps we check the mailbag i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressive VPN comm / ben alrighty so
the market is tanking again today as of
this morning it was dropping almost a
thousand points again below 25,000 which
means that we've seen a significant
market sell-off over the course of the
last five days all the way down from
about 29,000 all the way down to below
25,000 that is a market correction
anything below 10 percent down is a
market correction we have seen well
below 10 percent down and this is
leading to questions about how real this
drop is is this going to last are we
going to see a gradual rise again as the
market improves based on the market
pricing in all of the global supply
chain and disruptions what you are
seeing in the news today is people
trying to make political hay out of this
thing there's just no question this is
happening and it's really a points of
irritation to watch the media who are
definitely spinning people into a panic
over this thing try to pretend that they
are not involved in spinning people into
a panic over this thing or Democrats who
continue to claim that the government
response is completely lackluster then
claim held tear president Trump responds
to our claims that he's watching a
pandemic response I mean the fact is
that there are people out there who
without evidence are suggesting that a
pandemic is directly on the horizon that
the United States is gonna be hit with a
wave that it is unprepared for and not
only that but that President Trump is
solely responsible for this you've seen
Democrats out there claiming that the
stock market drop is somehow reflective
of president Trump's inability to quell
fears about the stock market Nancy
Pelosi for example said just this
yesterday said well President Trump was
trying to quell the markets the markets
dropped even as Trump was talking a
president said something so strange that
you really have to wonder you said the
reason the market dropped is because of
the debate the other night well the
market that dropped eighteen hundred
points before the debate the other night
the market dropped while he was speaking
yesterday in his press conference so you
know let's not let's not be silly
about what that is okay what that is is
global supply chains being disrupted the
fact is that the United States has very
strong underlying economic fundamentals
by every expert that I have talked to
and most experts out there the u.s. is
not the problem
with the global economy right now the
global economy is in trouble
specifically because of China and
because when China's supply chains
disrupt global supply chains it slows
down the ability of customers to buy it
slows down the ability of distributors
to distribute it slow down the ability
of producers to produce and this means
that you have holdups and that means
that companies are not able to fulfill
their orders it means that they are not
able to make money and then they are not
able to pay off those debts so China's
mishandling of this entire thing from
the very outset it just demonstrates the
dangers of investing heavy amounts of
money in fact the reason authoritarian
dictatorships that are more willing to
kill their own people for speaking
openly about threats like coronavirus
than they are to actually crack down on
coronavirus after the cat is already out
of the bag after the hen is already out
of the coop so the fact is this has
really nothing to do the United States
this has to do with China botching this
thing it has to do with the fact that
the European economy was already on
relatively shaky footing their growth
rates were already incredibly low we've
had on Mohamed el-erian who's now
getting all sorts of credit he's the
head of Allianz he's getting all sorts
of credit correctly so for forecasting a
couple of days ago don't buy into the
stock market drop yet wait a little bit
more because it's really a stock market
correction he's been on my show pointing
out that the fundamentals of the economy
in the United States are fine it's the
fundamentals of the economy in Europe
they're a real problem because Europe
has been blowing out the spending
because Europe has not actually got its
its debt in line with its spending
because European growth rates have been
low and because China's growth rates
have been unduly inflated and so he was
predicting for a long time that as
central bank's continue to manipulate
currencies in order to keep the market
up eventually they would run out of
bullets in their gun and you would have
to see some actual underlying
fundamental economic changes in place
yup and China in order to sustain growth
that's what you were seeing here you're
not seeing correction based on failures
of American policy you're seeing
Corrections here based on failures of
European and Chinese policy specifically
and you are seeing what happens when
vulnerable global supply lines actually
become vulnerable the fact is
globalization is fantastic in the sense
that if you can widely distribute the
factors of production across various
country lines you can make that cheaper
you can make it quicker you can make
products more easily and better all of
that is true it also means that just as
if you were playing a game a telephone
the chances are much better that the
longer the line goes on somebody is
going to miss the message somewhere in
the middle well the longer the supply
chain is the better chance is that there
is some sort of disruption in one of
those areas and that disruption is going
to affect the entire supply chain so
companies are constantly trying to
evaluate what are the what are the sort
of downside risks here this event is
sort of a black swan a black swan is an
event that is completely unforeseen it's
somewhat unforeseeable it's it's an
event that is so large and out of the
box that nobody has really planned for
it there was no real contingency plan
for it now I think it's fair to say that
people should have taken into account
that China was a significant area of
risk for a very long time mean the fact
is again it's an authoritarian regime
that means that they can shift policy at
a moment's notice but more than that
there have been a series of diseases
coming out of China ranging from bird
flu to SARS right and all of these
diseases coming out of China
maybe that should have been more
predictable that something like this
would happened but they were cropping up
once every few years they really did not
disrupt global supply lines the way that
this has disrupted global supply lines
so it was sort of an unforeseeable Black
Swan to blame that on Trump or to
suggest that that is reflective of
underlying problems in the American
economy is really not true particularly
since President ROM has been very harsh
on China right President Trump has
suggested that investments in China are
actually a mistake in the first place
that we should be bringing a lot more of
those investments home and I think
companies in the future are gonna think
twice about whether they want to invest
in China based on the factor that you
never know five years from now whether
China is simply going to step in and
declare that all business in the country
is done rather they're just not going to
operate anymore
and we'll get into more of this in just
one second and these sort of parochial
nature of Americans view of the economy
which is that everything in the American
economy is reliant on the American
economy alone that just is not true it's
never been true it's why it's always
very silly I mean
said this while Trump was president I
think it's very silly for any one
president to be credited with the stock
market drop or a stock market increase
unless the president takes policies that
are directly related to a stock market
crash very often global economic factors
have very little to do let's sort of the
tinkering around the margins the
presidents tend to do well get into more
of this in just one second first let's
talk about the problems with that you
may have with employees in a time where
economic contraction may be beginning
you want to be very careful about the
people you hire so let's say that
there's a guy who works for you and
let's let's call him Jared just just for
example Jared great guy and let's say
that one of the things that he does he
makes sure that you have your ads on
time and that you are fully kept abreast
of what exactly
advertisers are interested in hearing
and let's say that your show starts at
let's say I don't know like 8:00 a.m.
Pacific time let's say Jared just
decides one morning you know what
today's an important warning for me to
really you know get in there and get
into that supply line of the of the
advertising and so he just shows up that
like 8:15 and so suddenly you got a
staff of 30 people and they're all
waiting on Jared well at that point you
might be thinking to yourself hey how
about zip recruiter zip recruit calm
slash daily wired so the smartest way to
hire you can get great employees whether
they are new or replacements for Jared
no wonder four out of five employers who
post on super clear to get a quality
candidate within the very first day zip
recruiters powerful matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and invites them
to apply when you post on zip recruiter
that job listing get sent out to over a
hundred top job sites the results that
you get qualified candidates fast see
for yourself don't trust me try zip
recruiter for free right now go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter comm slash at Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash at daily wire
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire so you don't get stuck with
people like for example Jared zip
recruiter comm slash daily wiring and
zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI are
you improve your business by making your
employees better and by threatening your
employees with the possibility of
unemployment zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire okay so the New York Times
reporting on the real reasons why this
thing is dropping and that the lead is
always buried but the reality again is
that the cause of the global stock
market drop is not the United States
it's pretty much everybody else the
global stock market according to the New
York Times slid for the sixth straight
day on Thursday of course is sliding
again today
on Friday the sp500 slid 4.4% on
Thursday as I say again as of early
trading this morning the stock market
the Dow Jones Industrial Average was
down another thousand points the
downturn continued on Friday as asian
markets closed sharply lower and
european stocks tumbled at the start of
trading the widening scope of the health
crisis threatens to overwhelm global
supply chains especially in China the
world's second largest economy after the
United States in addition the outbreak
could crush consumer demand as people
limit travel or stay home even without a
government or to do so this is where the
uncertainty really comes in it's why
China has really botched this thing
because even if China had an outbreak
but there were transparent about what
exactly was going on the market could
price in the information that's what
markets do markets are fantastic at
pricing in for information there's a
theory of the stock market that is
called the if the efficient markets
theory there's sort of a strong version
or a weak version the strong efficient
markets theory says that no single
trader can ever beat the stock market in
general because it is a collectivized it
has collectivized aggregation of all
knowledge on a particular topic the more
information is available the more the
stock market is able to price it and
when you see tremendous stock market
drops like you've seen over the last
week what that means is tremendous
uncertainty it means that people are
trying to figure out exactly how much
uncertainty there is in the global
market exactly how much information has
been made available and the fact that
China has been very stingy about the
information that they've actually put
out there is the rationale for this trap
because investors are trying to figure
out okay well I'm not sure whether this
thing is gonna continue for a month or
six months I'm not sure whether we're
gonna see cancellations and public
events already in Switzerland they've
cancelled apparently all public events
over a thousand people not sure why a
thousand people is the limit but you
could easily see something like that in
the United States if this outbreak
starts to worsen he could see public
I mean sporting events could be shut
down for example Scott Clemmens the
chief investment strategist for private
bankers at Brown Brothers Harriman said
the outbreaks potential to alter
American consumers habits was at the
heart of the sell-off so the gree of the
consumers changed their behaviors they
stopped going out to eat they don't take
the vacation they cancel the business
trip that consumption that spending
personal consumption is 68 percent of
GDP over the past few days companies as
varied as United Airlines MasterCard and
Pfizer have said the outbreak poses a
threat to their 2020 earnings analyst at
Goldman Sachs predict that companies in
the S&P 500 would generate no profit
growth the entire year
as a result of the crisis because of its
severe decline in Chinese economic
activity when on Wednesday president
Trump tried to address the outbreak and
said that the risk to the United States
was low but people aren't really
confident in that because frankly even
the United States government doesn't
know enough about coronavirus again this
is the problem with China withholding
all sorts of information nobody knows
the death threat there are two real
factors as I discussed yesterday in
deciding what the risk factors are with
regard to coronavirus one is the
transmission rate and the other is the
death rate and we don't have good
information on either one of those
because China has not been revealing the
information in you are seeing widely
variant reports across the globe on the
impact of coronavirus right you are
seeing that coronavirus in Iran is
killing like a crapload of people but
koruna virus in Italy isn't killing that
many people which is not like a major
shot considering that Public Health and
Iran is garbage and the government of
Iran is garbage a bunch of their top
ministers have gotten coronavirus over
in Iran
according to farah naaz for CG and Rick
Gladstone reporting for The New York
Times a senior figure in Iran's
government who sits just a few seats
away from president Hassan rouhani a
cabinet meetings has fallen ill with
coronavirus making her Iran's seventh
official to test positive including one
prominent cleric who has died
there have been almost 300 deaths in
Iran that's just what's been reported
vice president ma su ma empty car mr.
rouhani's deputy for women's affairs in
the highest-ranking woman in the
government also one of the lead
revolutionaries during the Iranian
Revolution that in which they took
hostages she was actually one of the
hostage takers so she's a delightful
human being she's a confirmed corona
virus infection couldnt happen to a
nicer gal is quarantined at home that
his closure came a day after a cabinet
meeting in which she was in close
contact with other government leaders
including rouhani a photo posted by a
BBC Persian reporter on Twitter showed
she was sitting within a few yards of
rouhani she was known as Mary during the
Tehran hostage crisis four decades ago
Iran now appears to have the highest
number of government officials infected
by coronavirus who is officially first
reported in the holy Iranian city of Qom
on February 19th the disease is believed
to have spread to the country from China
which retains close economic relations
with Iran they have already reported
something like 26 I'm it was it was 245
people infected some 126 deaths already
but health experts estimate the number
of infections is far higher because the
country's fatality rate of about 20
percent seems so high compared to a
our countries meanwhile we've seen that
in Italy coronavirus is shutting down
public activity but we're not seeing
tons of deaths so there is a wide
difference in how countries death rates
are varying and transmission rates are
varying as well because we don't have
enough information the stock market is
trying to price in a tremendous amount
of uncertainty right now so when you see
that stock market dip well you should
recognize is that if as information
emerges it turns out that coronavirus is
really not going to have as grave an
impact on global health rates as it was
originally suspected it might then
you're gonna see the stock market
quickly reprice and people buy back in
the question is where the bottom is and
nobody really knows the answer my guess
is that we are approaching the bottom
because uncertainty seems like it's at
its height right now I'm not
recommending that people go on buy
stocks all I'm saying is that I would be
looking in the very near future to buy
stocks given the the stock market dip
that has taken place over the last few
days whenever the stock market drops
this much that tends to be a fairly good
time to buy stocks not a great time to
sell stocks you'll want to sell into a
dropping market buying into a dropping
markets a good idea and by the way when
people say my 401k is worth less that's
true your 401k is worth less but if
you're not cashing it out it doesn't
really matter and Warren Buffett was
once asked how much money he lost during
the 2007 2008 stock market crash and he
said I didn't lose a dime because I
didn't sell a stock as long as you don't
realize the loss the loss is not
realized which is something good to keep
in mind when you're panicking over the
value of your 401k if you don't have to
access your 401k right now then really
matter you can wait another year the
stock market goes back up which by the
way is the best investment strategy
buy-and-hold is a very very good
investment strategy over time playing
around with the stock market is
generally not a great investment
strategy the outbreak of coronavirus in
and around Milan is light-years from the
horrors of the plague for now only just
over a dozen people have died they were
elderly or with serious underlying
health conditions and this seems to be
the pattern even in the Chinese
statistics that have been made available
the death rates are much higher for
older people and people with
pre-existing conditions than they are
for people who are young nonetheless
people are staying home people are
freaked out you can see the pictures
from Milan it's a bustling city but now
basically everybody is staying home on
via Alessandro Manzoni hardly any cars
or people went by and long lines of
white taxis waited for fares that didn't
come and led down to Piazza del Duomo
where Milan's landmark Cathedral usually
crammed with tourists and people rushing
to the subway was mostly empty only a
few tourists often wearing nests show
up into pictures of themselves swarms in
great clouds of the pigeons they fed out
of their hands La Scala is still
shuttered the shopkeepers and bars in
stores stared absent-mindedly out the
windows or check their phones again none
of this is a grave shock everybody is
being very cautious at this point
meanwhile in the United States there has
been a lot of focus on California
because they're apparently 8400 people
who are being monitored in the state of
California our Ken doll of the governor
Gavin Newsom who has presided over one
of the worst health crises in modern
California history in terms of a massive
homeless crisis that has spread disease
in areas like downtown Los Angeles Gavin
Newsom came out yesterday and announced
that we are monitoring 8400 people in
that 33 confirmed cases of coronavirus
have cropped up in California alone
thousands and thousands of other people
have come in on more traditional flights
through the state of California some
8400 plus are currently being monitored
with 49 local jurisdictions doing those
protocols and monitoring as it relates
to more traditional commercial flights
that came in from points of concern and
potential points of contact particularly
in Asia
okay so 8400 people is a lot of people
to monitor the people they're monitoring
are people who have had points of
contact in China we have seen the first
case in California this is the one
that's that's kind of freaky the first
case of what they call a community
infection meaning we have no idea where
the person got the corona virus
infection according to the New York
Times coronavirus diagnosis in
California is highlighting testing flaws
doctors suspected that one person was
infected with corona virus for days but
the patient didn't fit the federal
criteria because they hadn't been in
contact with anyone from China and they
weren't tested for days which means
they're running around the state of
California without any testing protocol
in place even before the announcement on
Wednesday frustration had been mounting
among health providers and medical
experts that the agency was testing too
few Americans which may slow
preparations for an outbreak and may
obscure the scope of infections lauren
lawrence our director of operations at
johns hopkins office of critical event
preparedness and response says I think
the diagnostic issues the single most
important thing that keeps me up at
night right now CDC officials said on
Thursday they had not been made aware
that doctors in California made an
urgent appeal for diagnostic testing of
the woman by the end of the day the
agency had revised and broadened its
testing criteria adding to the
of Americans who qualify right now
they're saying there is a shortage of
testing kits so all the talk about
testing everybody that apparently is is
not a thing that that is possible right
now
CDC is worrying that maybe the health
system gets overwhelmed but the fact is
that we are going to be spending
billions of dollars on this thing
I mean billions of dollars can we're
gonna get into more of what the
government has been doing where the
shortcomings are in just one second
first let's talk about the problems with
fixing your car so you know something
breaks down your car your car is no more
complex than ever you probably can't go
to the local auto parts store get what
you need and walk out with exactly the
right part for your car because parts
have become parts to become so specific
instead what you need is to use the
power of the Internet chain stores have
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourselfers alike
and here's the thing rockauto.com
doesn't Rock Auto calm always offers the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like Airlines do I spend up to
twice as much for the same part the
rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brand's
specifications and prices you prefer
rockauto.com has everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet whether
it's for your classic or daily driver
and get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door
Rock Auto comm is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right Shapiro's in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you again the power of the
internet making your life better every
day
Rock Auto dot-com rich appear on there
how did you hear about us box they know
that we say you and get all the parts at
the best possible price that you could
ever wish for
okay so updates from ABC News the FDA is
now announcing that the issue of a drug
shortage is is a possibility again these
drugs will be ramped up fairly quickly
you would imagine Japan has reported a
couple additional time in princess
cruise ship deaths the individuals were
a British man and a Japanese woman they
were the fifth and sixth passengers to
die from corona virus after being aboard
the quarantined cruise ship of course
like 700 people were actually infected
on that quarantine cruise ship so not a
huge surprise that that many people died
because that if there were 800 people
infected aboard the cruise ship in six
or seven people died that's obviously
tragic and it's obviously terrible but
that mean
the death rate is not 10% or 20% or even
5% so the the right now
China still leads the way in terms of
number of infections apparently at least
2,800 people according to the WHI of
South Korea has the second highest
national total of coronavirus cases
behind China with more than 81 thousand
people tested in that country about 2300
had tested positive for a corona virus
more than 30 thousand others were
waiting test results at this point
meanwhile a majority of America of the
cases who are on board the diamond
Princess cruise ships the the people in
the United States were diagnosed with
the disease they were on board that time
in princess cruise ship that was placed
under quarantine in Japanese waters no
American has yet died from corona virus
when the CDC is investigating the source
of the various infections that have been
seen around the country the FDA said on
Thursday it was not aware of any reports
at this time of human illnesses that
suggests that corona virus can be
transmitted by food or by food packaging
meanwhile there's the other big story
today from the US government is that a
whistleblower within the US Department
of Health and Human Services had filed a
complaint alleging that more than a
dozen workers were sent to receive the
first Americans repatriated from Wuhan
China without proper training or
protective gear for coronavirus
infection control this was reported by
The Washington Post they suggest that
the corona virus basically was treated
without any sort of protective gear
according to this whistleblower the
underlying complaint apparently has not
been substantiated at this point a
spokesperson for the US Office of
Special Counsel confirmed it received
the whistleblower complaint and that the
case has been assigned when asked for
comment US Department of Health and
Human Services spokesperson Katelyn
Oakley told ABC News we take all
whistleblower complaints very seriously
and are providing the complainants all
appropriate protections under The
Whistleblower Protection Act we're
evaluating the complaint have nothing
further to add at this time ABC News has
not revealed the complaint lawyers
representing the whistleblower have
refused to provide the complaint one of
the whistleblowers attorneys told ABC
News that the allegations laid forth are
accurate he says we are hopeful Congress
in the OSC will investigate this case in
a timely and comprehensive manner
there's no evidence by the way that
anybody who actually met the folks
coming back from Wuhan that any of those
those folks were actually infected with
corona virus nonetheless that is leading
two questions about the the federal
handling of this entire situation now
with all of that set there's no question
that the Democrats and the media are
making hay out of all this brian Stelter
was saying we may be looking at a crisis
and meanwhile we're having a crisis in
leadership okay we're not anywhere near
a crisis point in the United States at
this point guys we are just not we're
not the fact is that we have
double-digit numbers of actual infected
in the United States has only 60 total
infected in the United States in a
country of 330 million people we have
zero deaths so far so the notion that we
are like on the verge of a widespread
outbreak now this stuff is fluid it
could move but there's no evidence at
this point that a pandemic is in the
offing in the United States particularly
since the US has done a fairly good job
it seems so far of quarantine people
meanwhile over in Israel there are
reports that Israeli scientists are on
the cusp of developing the first vaccine
against the novel coronavirus according
to Science and Technology Minister Ophir
akunis I look forward to Bernie Sanders
receded to Lieb and Omaha Nome are
suggesting boycott divestment and
sanction from the corona virus vaccine
because it's produced in Israel if all
goes as planned the vaccine could be
ready within a few weeks and available
in 90 days according to a press release
congratulations to the Galilee Research
Institute on this exciting breakthrough
said the Science and Technology Minister
akunis I'm confident there will be
further rapid progress enabling us to
provide a needed response to the grave
of global kovat 19 threat for the past
four years scientists have been
developing a vaccine against infectious
bronchitis virus which causes a
bronchial disease affecting poultry the
effectiveness of that vaccine had been
proven in preclinical trials so we'll
see you know how well this this
coronavirus vaccine works but at least
there are some glimmers of hope on the
horizon but this is not stopping anybody
in the media from speculating at the end
of the world is upon us we're gonna get
to that in a second because that really
is the big story in the United States
right now the big story is not the
actual corona virus outbreak because
there is no corona virus outbreak in the
United States the big story in the
United States is twofold one the drop in
the stock market which again is not
attributable attributable to Trump it is
attributable to the weakness in the
global economy and the fact that trying
to has screwed everything up and to it
is the Democrats in the media trying to
spin this thing into crisis and again
the evidence just ain't there for crisis
at this point we'll get there in just
one second first let's talk about making
your business more efficient now now
would be the time to think about making
your business more efficient right I
mean we may be looking at the
ability of an economic downturn Goldman
Sachs suggesting the sp500 companies are
not gonna have profits this year if your
business is a business that requires
profit one thing that you definitely
need is control of your data right we
hear the daily wire we have to have our
eye on our data at all times because
that is how we know where the holes in
our business are you need that too and
this is why you should be checking out
NetSuite by Oracle whether you're doing
a million 10 million or hundreds of
millions in revenue
NetSuite by Oracle gives you the tools
you need to accelerate your growth with
NetSuite you get a full picture of your
business finance inventory HR customers
and more it's everything you need to
grow all in one place directly from your
phone or computer
NetSuite will give you the visibility
and control you need to make the right
decisions and grow with confidence
that's why NetSuite customers grow
faster than the S&P 500 NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
it's trusted by more than 19,000
companies it is the last system you will
ever need NetSuite because business
grows here schedule your free products
tour right this moment receive your free
guide seven key strategies to grow your
profits at NetSuite comm slash pen that
is NetSuite comm /ban
ETSU ite comm slash man NetSuite dot-com
slash Bend go check them out right now
and make your business more efficient
okay so the Democrats meanwhile have
been trying to spend this thing as a
failure to the Trump administration as I
say president Trump's original comments
about the the coronavirus were very
silly right he came out and then he
suggested that he spelled it wrong and
he came out and he said that we're on
the verge of a vaccine in the United
States that wasn't true and then his
people had to come out and say he meant
ebola vaccine and what the president
should have done is what all presidents
should do in case of crisis immediately
turn to your experts put your experts in
charge and then just hands-off and my
experts are in charge they know
epidemiology better than the night of a
very easy solution the president however
has an unfortunate habit of running over
twitter and then just saying things and
that of course is not smart however the
President does have a right to push back
against Democrats who have been claiming
falsely that the end of the world is
upon us even The Associated Press called
out Democrats yesterday
The Associated Press which is no
right-wing source reported that
Democrats who keep suggesting that
President Trump is defunding the CDC the
Centers for Disease Control or
decreasing the National Institute for
Health budget the AAP says these people
are wrong you say that this is just not
true
Trump's budgets proposed cuts to public
health only to be over
by Congress where there's strong
bipartisan support for agencies like the
CDC and the NIH instead funding has
increased
indeed the money the government disease
detectives first tapped to fight the
latest outbreak was a congressional fund
created for health emergencies some
public health experts say a bigger
concern than White House budgets is the
steady erosion of a CDC grant program
for state and local public health
emergency preparedness but that decline
was set in motion by a congressional
budget management measure that comes
before Trump the broader point about
there being nobody here to coordinate
the response is not true the Public
Health's I mean this is the AP right is
not me this is the AP the public health
system has a playbook to follow for
pandemic preparation regardless of whose
presidents or whether specific
instructions are coming from the White
House those plans were put into place in
anticipation of another flu pandemic but
are designed to work for any respiratory
born disease among the health
authorities overseeing the work our
doctor and shook at CDC's principle
deputy secretary and veteran of previous
outbreaks and dr. Anthony Fauci NIH has
infectious disease chief who has advised
six presidents John Auerbach president
of the non partisan trust for America's
Health says the CDC's response has been
excellent as it has been in the past our
Brock says CDC's top scientific grants
remains stable during the past three
years now there may be problems going
forward but that is not because of cuts
that Trump's supposedly undertook and
this is but this is not stopping the
media from speculating and speculating
and speculating I mean they they are
indeed trying to whip people into a
frenzy over all this which by the way
may provide you a buying opportunity in
the stock market if the stock market is
responding it's that ridiculous
feeding frenzy the Washington Post has
several pieces today trying to suggest
that the White House response is
lackluster despite the fact that were
like a week into the White House
response according to Beth Reinhart emma
brown and nina sativa over at the
washington post the White House official
charged with leading the US response to
deadly pandemics left nearly two years
ago as his global health security team
was disbanded federal funding for
preventing and mitigating the spread of
infectious disease has been repeatedly
threatened since President from
selection but by the way repeatedly
threatened does not mean that it was cut
it was not actually cut by the way this
is one area of government spending that
actually makes a difference if you're
talking about pandemic prevention there
are thousand other places to cut in
American government pandemic prevention
seems like a fairly good place to
actually put some federal money despite
the mounting threat of a corona virus
outbreak in the United States Trump says
has no regrets about those actions and
that expertise and resources can be
quickly ramped up to meet current needs
but again the cuts never took place
so the washington post is proclaiming
that cuts took place that never happened
the washington post is trying to stir up
a a feeling of unease about the federal
government's response when again there's
no evidence that the CDC at the top
levels is understaffed there's no
evidence that the CDC is underfunded at
this point Trump is going back to
Congress for more money tomorrow
if we have to spend money it's not as
though the federal government isn't
unable to spend money the federal
government spends four trillion dollars
a year a few billion dollars is not
going to like the question is where you
allocate for that in future budgets to
repay but let's you forget we have 22
trillion dollars in debt here in the
United States and federally undertaken
debt in the United States so racking up
a few more billion ain't gonna incan
bankrupt the United States former
federal officials and public health
experts argue that an effective response
to an epidemiological crisis demands
sustained planning and investment while
the administration's response to
coronavirus says the Washington Post has
been criticized in recent weeks as slow
and disjointed people in and outside the
White House warned for years the nation
is ill-prepared for a dangerous pandemic
okay let me just remind you people said
exactly the same thing about Ebola
people said exactly the same thing about
bird flu there has yet to be a federal
response to a disaster in my lifetime
and which people said ah the federal
government really handled that thing
beautifully because guess what the
federal government ain't God they can
only do what they can do and the fact is
that most of the time they're gonna
botch something because that's what the
federal government does they're a big
battery the only question is whether
they are the best available resource at
this given point in time and right now
they they basically are Tom Ingoldsby
director of the Johns Hopkins center for
health security says you built a fire
department ahead of time you don't wait
for a fire there's an under appreciation
for the amount of time and resources
required to build a prepared system but
again we have a prepared system when it
comes to flu the question is how large
the ramped up is President Obama in 2014
appointed Ronald Klain a veteran
Democratic operative to serve as Ebola
czar now by the way this should be noted
remember that time when everybody said
that it's very bad that Mike Pence was
made the the coronaviruses are here
people ripping on Mike Pence
specifically ripping on my pens because
when he was governor of Indiana he
didn't stand in favor of needle
exchanges and so they blame him for an
HIV outbreak because of needle exchanges
which is just an absurdity at the
highest
level hey it is not the responsibility
of the government to provide you free
needles clean needles so you can shoot
up okay that is a very controversial
public policy issue to blame to blame
Mike Pence for an HIV outbreak because
he didn't provide government provided
free needles to people is just an insane
contention nonetheless people are
ripping on pence Wow how could you
appoint pence to this thing President
Trump
President Obama appointed Ronald clay in
a democratic operative the Obama
administration according to the
Washington Post also set up a special
National Security Council team to
oversee epidemic preparedness on a
permanent basis the global health
security team continued to operate
during Trump's first year in office
before John Bolton dismantled the unit
when he took over as NSA in 2018 that
led to the abrupt departure of its
leader Rear Admiral Timothy Siemer who
had led the White House's anti-malaria
efforts under Obama and George W Bush
okay but would we be significantly
better off if that guy were employed
right now not a ton of evidence to
suggest that that would be the case it
was a clear loss and now we are behind
the boss and a former White House
official familiar with a tzemre steam
they had the contacts in the
relationships and knew who to talk to
okay I have a feeling that people can
find phone numbers in the federal
government like really I have a feeling
that this is just trying to whip people
into a ridiculous level of frenzy over
government shortcomings that have yet to
be proved and the Washington Post and
they ran like three pieces like this
yesterday they ran a bunch of pieces
like this yesterday trying to suggest
shortcomings in the White House this is
a political issue I mean the Democrats
are trying to make this political and it
really should not be political Mike
Pence yesterday came out he said listen
we have no higher priority than
coronavirus I mean we are working on
this thing President Donald Trump has no
higher priority than the health safety
and well-being of the American people as
the president said yesterday we're ready
we're ready for anything
yesterday President Trump directed me to
lead a whole-of-government approach to
address the corona virus in this country
and I promise you we will continue to
bring the full resources of the federal
government to bear to protect the
American people
and you know what that's probably true I
mean and when I said it's probably
dreaming like what would be the upside
of not bringing in the full force of the
federal government
on something that's at the tip of
everybody's tongue what pen says there
is the proper response that is the
proper response Democrats however are
trying to complain about this thing
endlessly
I mean it's so bad that even Democrats
were storming out of a meeting with
other Democrats after Democrats we're
complaining about the Trump response
we'll bring you that story in just one
second first it is that glorious time of
the week when I give a shout out to a
daily water subscriber today it's Daniel
Stoll on Twitter who's clearly living
the dream in this picture Daniel is
holding the world's most elite beverage
vessel while driving his tractor through
some gorgeous farm property murica the
caption reads listening to Apollo 11
what we saw fantastic podcast while
operating from my John Deere command
module drinking some black coffee in my
real daily wire left his tier similar
hashtag left is tears tumblr that is
indeed a fantastic product produced with
our friend Bill Whittle if you haven't
already I highly recommend checking out
his latest show the cold war what we saw
it's really good stuff thanks for the
pec Daniel and thank you most of all for
serving our nation as a United States
Marine seriously dude what a stud also
guess why tomorrow is Saturday February
29 that makes it a leap day a day that
only comes once every four years will my
child be born on leap day who the hell
knows frankly that's a good thing
because we're about to offer you an
amazing deal to become a daily wire
insider plus member the deal would
literally bankrupt us if we actually
tried to run it more than one day so
tomorrow go to daily wire comm slash
subscribe and try to bankrupt us by
taking advantage of this very special
offer
there is no coupon code needed but this
offer is good for tomorrow only by
tomorrow only so it's extremely
time-sensitive it expires at midnight
Pacific time 3 a.m. for those of you on
the East Coast be sure to check out our
website anywhere you follow us on social
media I'll also be doing a leap day drop
on my podcast feed so you can hear more
about the deal I really can't wait to
share this with you so go check it out
while you have the chance remember that
is daily wire calm slash subscribe your
listenings the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
how irritating has the Democratic and
media response been on this it's even
irritating other Democrats according to
Politico several House Republicans
walked out of a closed door of
coronavirus meeting on Friday with Trump
health officials in protest after a
senior Democrat who looks a lot like
Keith Richards for some reason blasted
the Trump administration's handling of
the response effort representative rosa
DeLauro of Connecticut kicked off the
briefing sharply criticizing the
administration as disorganized and
lacking urgency in combating the
coronavirus her eight-minute speech
frustrated Republicans and some
Democrats assembled to hear from the
slate of officials from the CDC NIH and
State Department by the way notice what
political didn't put in the headline he
a Republicans storm out of coronavirus
briefing after Democrat rips Trump's
response there's only one problem other
Democrats were pissed off at DeLauro
they were like what are you doing like
we're all on the same page here
seriously this is we're really
representative Paul Mitchell of Michigan
Republicans and if I wanted here the
politics of it I read Politico Deloris
comments were indicative of the growing
political tensions around the Trump
administration's handling of the
coronavirus response Trump who's tried
to publicly downplay the virus through
misleading claims just after midnight
took to Twitter to complain the
Democrats were pinning the crisis on him
and of course that's true I mean the
Democrats are trying to pin the crisis
on him Trump says he tweeted out so the
corona virus which started in China and
spread to various countries throughout
the world but very slowly in the u.s.
because President Trump closed our
border and ended flights very early is
now being blamed by the do-nothing
Democrats to be the fault of Trump and
then he said that Democratic lawmakers
were wasting time on other legislative
priorities he says the do-nothing
Democrats were busy wasting time on the
immigration hoax and anything else they
could do to make the Republican party
look bad well I was busy calling early
border and flight closings put us way
ahead in our battle with coronavirus
demin called it very wrong that's kind
of factual by the way again
even Democrats were annoyed by this
ridiculous rosa DeLauro character
grandstanding on this issue Donna
shillelagh who led the Health Department
under Bill Clinton said no one wanted to
hear that either Democrats or
Republicans we just wanted to hear the
substance DeLauro the leading health
health appropriator accused the
administration of a lack of urgency and
warned there were several crucial
questions that remained unanswered as
lawmakers transferred to a bigger room a
visibly frustrated to Laura told
colleagues she didn't give a rat's ass
and about the reaction and the members
needed answers from the administration
the briefing
led by the CDC director Robert Redfield
and NIH infectious disease specialist
Tonio Qi who is called to update members
on the state of the corona viruses
spread asked about an HHS whistleblower
complaint officials did not directly
contradict the allegations but they
insisted they believed everyone is
properly trained and protocols were
followed that was about that
whistleblower complaint mentioned
earlier meanwhile CNN trying to claim
that Trump is silencing scientists this
is based on the New York Times piece
that points out that the White House is
now running all messaging through my
Pence which again makes a lot of sense
okay it makes a lot of sense you want to
have a singular message coming out of
the administration if there is a
cover-up okay if it turns out that the
corona virus outbreak is much more
widespread then that will damage the
administration far worse than anything
else radical transparency is called for
and the administration I think knows
this what they don't want is exactly
what has happened a bunch of low-level
officials running out and saying
different things and then the media
reporting chaos in the administration so
the media are trying to create this
catch-22 if you have a bunch of
low-level officials running out there
uncoordinated saying different things
then they say chaos in the
administration no one's heading this up
it's a complete disaster Joe okay and
then if you have one person heading it
like pens and all the messaging is going
through Penn Senate's they've bottled
Meck this thing this is censorship okay
so in other words there's nothing that
Trump can do right here right there's
nothing that pens can do right here is
CNN trying yesterday to suggest that
Trump was silencing scientists to
prevent them from talking about
coronavirus which is absolutely absurd
the problem occurs when a you have a
president who starts with very little
credibility and then B you have an
administration that has had mixed
messages and what the people want is the
truth and the question is whether you
can get the truth more from the
scientists or whether you believe the
politicians are the right people to get
the truth when scientists use the word
pandemic they don't take that lightly
and they say that it is a possibility
and if they are muzzled from talking
about that possibility I think that
could threaten Public Health okay
muzzled from talking
no one's muzzling anybody okay seriously
nobody is muscling anybody the problem
is that there are a bunch of different
stories coming out and that is shocking
the stock market because when you are
getting multiple different stories that
raises the level of uncertainty we has a
problem you actually want to call if you
want a coordinated response then you
want to coordinated response if you want
an uncoordinated discombobulated
response then by all means don't
some sort of head at the head of the
system this is pure ridiculousness from
the media the RNC chair
Ronna Romney McDaniel she came out and
she said like this is this is ridiculous
Schumer and Pelosi are acting like
political hacks we should all be on the
same page with this thing this of course
is true they're trying to stoke fear and
the American people this is a time when
Americans usually come together and they
put aside their political differences
and they say how can I help this
president how can I make sure we calm
the fears of the American people
and that's precisely the opposite of
what Democrats are doing they're
politicizing this we are preparing we're
putting protocols in place and we're
going to be ready and Democrats should
be joining him and saying guess what
we're gonna work together across party
lines to make sure our country safe and
instead they're politicizing it which
they've done with every single issue
when it comes to this president and that
is why they're just so shameful and they
haven't helped solve many many problems
that the American people are facing
she's saying she speaks truth she speaks
truth okay that is a hundred percent
true I mean you can see in the
Washington Post The Washington Post has
another piece today about how Trump is
mean to bureaucrats
so obviously this threatens the country
because Trump has ripped on the deep
state throughout his more than three
years as presidents as the Washington
Post Trump is obsessed at times
conspiratorial over what he calls the
deep state the thousands of career
government specialists in national
security intelligence science in other
areas whose expertise he shuns in part
because he suspects their disloyal
saboteurs and so with the first case of
coronavirus not tied to foreign travel
being announced in California on
Wednesday Trump finds himself grappling
with a crisis for which his record
suggests he's particularly ill suited to
respond so because Trump is ripping on
his Intel people because they were in
fact leaking a bunch of crap about him
for years on end this means he's
ill-equipped to respond by letting
health officers do their job I mean it
come on come on come on this is exactly
what Democrats are looking for it's this
doesn't mean that Trump can't handle
this better I've said it I said it right
from beginning president Trump should be
quiet now let pens handle this thing and
not say a word about it that's what he
should do and he should let his people
handle it but to proclaim that we are in
the midst of a of a public-relations in
Trump caused crisis is just missing the
fact that the rest of the world is the
source of coronavirus is the source of
the global economic risk that the United
States is actually the only solid island
in a sea of chaos and meanwhile
are approaching me South Carolina
primary that is supposed to happen
tomorrow and this is Joe Biden's last
gasp if Joe Biden doesn't win big in
South Carolina this sucker is over and
Bernie Sanders is the nominee even if
Joe Biden does win in South Carolina
there's the possibility that Bernie
Sanders runs away with this thing anyway
we've now been treated to a bevy of new
polling data there are three new polls
out today one from data for progress a
democratic firm it shows that Joe Biden
up thirty four twenty five over Bernie
Sanders won from the posting Currier in
in South Carolina which has Biden over a
very narrow lead Sanders he's got 28 24
over Sanders and then there's an Emerson
poll which shows Biden blowing Sanders
the eff out blowing him out 41 225 like
really blowing him out Biden needs a
double-digit victory here he needs at
least a double-digit victory
if he wins narrow Sanders takes the
nomination if he wins broad then all of
a sudden you might see a bump for Joe
Biden you're starting to see Democrats
again sort of they're splitting the baby
so on the one hand they really don't
want Bernie to be the nominee on the
other hand they're sort of creating a
back-up plan where they can try to
retcon Bernie's history as I mentioned
yesterday Nancy Pelosi yesterday she
says well you know if we have to support
Bernie's of genda I guess I guess we
will I mean don't like him so much but I
mean I guess we'll do it whoever our
nominee is we will support with respect
for his or her positions and hopefully
with their respect for our positions as
well so we have made a decision to win
and as I say to the members if you make
a decision to win you have to make every
subsequent decision to win no friction
no nothing to stay on the path to
victory because it's so very important
okay so yes we will get behind Bernie
Sanders if we have to if we have to at
the same press conference she suggested
that if Bernie goes into the convention
with a plurality of Delegates but not a
majority of Delegates then she will not
necessarily support Bernie Sanders so
there they are adjusting to the
possibility of Bernie Sanders without
handing over the without handing over
the keys to the car to Bernie Sanders at
this point there's a reason for that
Rahm Emanuel former chief of staff to
Barack Obama and of course mayor of
Chicago for mayor of Chicago he says
listen for all this talk about Bernie
driving up turnout in in controversial
areas it ain't happened
does not have the turnout numbers the
turnout model that he's looking at it
has not materialized one of the things
I'm concerned about right now is that
while viewership in the debates are up
mm-hmm
2018 big turnout 2019 big turnout for
Democrats participation in our primaries
is not so it's barely surpassing 2016
yeah that's a flashing yellow light and
it is indeed a flashing yellow light
again you're starting to see Democrats
sort of hedged their bets here by
defending every bad thing that Bernie
ever does so remember that time that the
entire media proclaimed that the
Republican Party been hijacked by Trump
and now everybody approves his worst
excesses yeah all of that's true Bernie
Sanders like every single elements of it
so yesterday House Republicans tried to
bring to the floor a resolution
condemning Bernie Sanders for his
comments over Cuba and condemning Cuba's
human rights abuses and Democrats voted
to block the resolution here's
representative Mario diaz-balart from
Florida Republican talking about it but
I remind senator Sanders and the
progressive movement that the Castro
regime is not only a threat a threat to
the national security interests of the
United States but also to the
democracies that democracies in our
hemisphere I want to remind senator
Sanders of Cuba's close relationship of
the Cuban regime's close relationship
with some of the world's worst thugs and
that of course is true but it's not
really gonna matter because Democrats
have decided that they will defend
anything and everything with regard to
Bernie Sanders meanwhile Joe Biden
continues again in these polls in South
Carolina to do very well we're gonna
know within 24 hours whether Joe Biden's
candidacy is still alive he may not be
he continues to just stumble around out
there yesterday on the campaign trail
Joe Biden randomly started talking about
ladies taking off their clothes and why
you're not allowed to touch them which
is a very very weird thing to do no man
that's right to lay a hand on a woman
for any other reason in self-defense and
I'm gonna make the controversial
statements always made if someone in
this room got up took off all our
clothes and walked out the door no man
is a right to touch her zero for
indecent exposure
whoa indecent exposure and no assault
whoa every second clapping confusedly
what's even talking about like what what
what's going on yeah so that those are
your choices Democrats a senile old dude
with corrupt ties to his son maybe or at
least his son is corrupt or the bat
bleep loony communist who spends his
entire career being a useless piece of
crap so congratulations this is the
choice you have made for yourself
meanwhile Michael Bloomberg continues to
be a weapon against Bernie Sanders he
released some medical information about
the about his heart health and and he
said that that senator Sanders ought to
do the same I mean it is pretty
incredible that Sanders had a heart
attack on the campaign trail last year
and he has not released his complete
health records and everybody's like oh
well I guess no big deal no biggie
gonna call it in to our radio show
yesterday who asked a question what
happens if Bernie Sanders gets nominate
and then god forbid something happens to
him right who actually takes the
nomination the answer by the way is that
the DNC gets to appoint the replacement
for anybody who had plots before an
election but you know that's never
happened before in American history in a
new report from CNN Bloomberg campaign
spokesman Stu lesson ripped Sanders for
not releasing the same left ventricular
ejection fraction data Bloomberg did in
his own health report that's a very
specific report talking about the
ability of the heart to continue pumping
blood properly Lester said releasing the
single scientific number about heart
health could starts put to rest any
concerns about senator Sanders is
secrecy about his recent heart attack
said my Bloomberg's doctor shared Mike's
number well senator Sanders asked his
doctor to do the same okay the answer of
course is no Sanders says we're not
going to be releasing any more health
records which is weird because earlier
in the campaign he said he was gonna
release all of these health records
suffice it to say that this this
Democratic field is is so weak at this
point that the two choices at the top
neither one of them seems to be a
massive a massive victory for Democrats
with
that said again there are these black
swans that are out there this
coronavirus is a Black Swan it does it
does really up turn the entire
conventional wisdom about the selection
I mean if the stock market were to
continue to drop if the economy were to
stagnate then everything is on the table
and things get really ugly really
quickly so obviously we'll continue to
bring you all the updates on all of this
ok time for a quick thing I like and
then we'll do a couple of things that I
hate so things that I like today there's
a great kind of sci-fi / horror film
that came out just a couple of years ago
it didn't get the kind of attention that
it should it made some money it was at
the budget on it was like three to five
million dollars it was a really well
made film really great I really like it
a lot it's a movie called upgrade I
heard about it honestly on a on a
podcast done by my friend Sonny bunch
over at rubella media which you should
go check out pretty cool it's it's got
all sorts of good Hollywood content
anyway
and suddenly recommended it along with
someone's co-host the movie is really
first-rate I watched it this week the
basic premise of the film is that there
is a guy who is attacked and left for
dead basically his girlfriend his wife
is killed he's attacked and left for
dead he's made a quadriplegic in the
process and there and he knows sort of
this this tech type who implants in him
something called stem and stem allows
him to regain the use of his functions
but stem also does more than that stem
is infiltrating his brain and having
conversations with him the whole time
sort of like a user system talking to
you I mean it's almost like you talking
to Siri basically it's like Siri in his
head who's helping him run his limbs the
movies really well-made it's beautifully
produced and it's supremely creepy
because you'd think that it's basically
just a revenge thriller it is not just a
revenge thriller it really is sort of a
parable about the dangers of science and
tech overtaking your life here's a
little bit of a preview of upgrade
[Music]
it's well-acted you can see actually one
of the things that's kind of cool is how
the axle moves he acts as though he's
not actually in control of his limbs
which is pretty kind of hard to do so
it's it's pretty great actually I mean I
will say the movie moves incredibly
quickly it's it's got a good script it's
well acted so if you're looking for kind
of edits and short III will say I'm a
big fan of movies and understand what
their actual length ought to be this
film runs about an hour and 35 and it
should run about an hour 35 and it's
really solid it's really tight good film
go check it out this weekend if you're
looking for something fun and creepy to
watch upgrade okay time for a couple of
things that I hate right thing that I
hate number one so there is a video that
has now gone viral on tic-tock tic-tock
is one of these things for the Jen's
ears and Millennials it basically you
you upload these these little videos to
tic toc they're supposed to be sort of
edited into what 10 15 seconds or
something and then you and then
basically it acts almost like snapchat
except they don't disappear you put them
out publicly and then people view them
this video has been viewed a bajillion
times now because it's just horrifying
and disgusting basically it's a it's a
young woman who goes with her friend to
get an abortion and she is happy the
whole way through she goes there and
she's making fun of people who are at
the abortion clinic who seemed to be a
little bit upset about you know killing
a baby and here is a little bit of the
tick-tock video I'll read it to you
because a lot of it is done in Texas
abortion time take two take two
it's a pregnancy test and then she's
laughing nervous laugh there's to
abortion moves people want to add and
then her partying it up for like pumping
her fists and smiling while she gets an
abortion and then it shows the
ultrasound as that baby is as that fetus
is sucked into a tube so let me just
point something out about the modern
American left I'm old enough to remember
when people on the left at least
acknowledged the moral quandary involved
in abortion Amer I'm old enough to
remember safe legal and rare which was
the Bill Clinton line now it never made
any logical sense but at least it made a
certain amount of emotional sense it
didn't make any logical sense because if
you believe that it's a wrong and it
should not be legal right but if you are
at least making the moral at least if
you're making the emotional case that
there is something that is worthy of
consideration here that at least is
living in the realm of reality acting as
though it is nothing more than getting a
polyp removed to take an incipient human
life and then kill it and by the way
what does that mean abortion take two is
that her second abortion I mean that's
all I can take away from that because I
really don't know what that means
her celebrating fist-pumping as though
this is women's empowerment this is what
our culture has done Zinn the notion of
femininity it's absolutely horrifying so
my wife is like literally on the verge
of giving birth right to child number
three thank God thank God everything
looks healthy thank God
yeah I can tell you that from the very
instant we knew she was pregnant
obviously this was now a part of our
life and not only was this a part of our
life this was an individual soul that
was going to have a place in this world
and if God forbid something had happened
to that child we would have mourned for
the unborn child I mean that that is the
way that Meghan McCain had beautiful
column Balthus for the New York Times
when she had a miscarriage people mourn
for their unborn children they don't
know them as well as they know they're
born children obviously but this is
still a thing with moral weight this is
still so the vision of people
celebrating candy shout your abortion
movement as though it is a mark of
femininity and womanhood to cast out
that which most makes you a woman and
yes it does okay I'm sorry pregnancy is
one of the things that makes you most a
woman as distinguished from most a man
it's not what makes me most a human
being what reason makes you most a human
being but your capacity to have a child
is one of the key features of being a
woman as opposed to being a biological
man and to pretend that that doesn't
matter
and to pretend that femininity is to
actively cast that out that female
empowerment is to take that which makes
you most uniquely female your superpower
right it is a superpower you're able to
grow a child in your own body and then
feed that child using your own that's a
superpower man that is a superpower and
to pretend that that is something
negative and bad and that casting that
child out and that killing that unborn
human being that that is some sort of
mark of bravery or femininity that
you're more of a woman for doing that
than you would be if you had taken the
child determine somehow it's degrading
to you as a woman right not as a human
being as a woman to carry a child to
term and have that child to exercise
your superpower
maybe it's the honest to god it's the
equivalent of Superman deliberately
grounding himself and then saying I feel
more like a Kryptonian today like that's
just not the way that this works your
superpower is this thing this is talk to
any woman who has been pregnant this is
just a meet point okay this is a my wife
point this is any woman who's been
pregnant point okay this is an amazing
amazing gift that God has given you or
Nature has given you if you don't
believe in God and that gift that
amazing gift to take that and to degrade
that to pretend that the mark of
womanhood is to take that which most
makes you a woman and then throw it away
is really insane I mean it truly is and
the celebration is just it's beyond the
moral pale but that is our society now
our society as you celebrate the sin
it's not enough to just acknowledge that
a sin is being committed or to say
listen I believe I should have the right
to commit the sin even if I think it's a
sin even if I think it's bad I think I
should have the right to commit the sin
it's not a good argument but at least
that's an argument but to celebrate the
sin is an act of evil to celebrate doing
something that harms another human being
and by the way I'm not seeing any
evidence in the image she took a
pregnancy test she doesn't look as
though she was forced into the sex in
this particular video if that is
different then I will amend that
statement but I've seen no information
to suggest that if she had consensual
sex with a person and then she got
pregnant which is a result of consensual
sex in many cases turns out these two
things are interlinked and then her
natural response is to celebrate
presumably both the bogy casual sex and
then also the abortion how does this
make anybody a better human being how
does this make society better how does
this make femininity better how does
this strengthen womanhood
any real way if you don't watch that if
you watch that you're not horrified
I'll tell you're doing morality wrong
whether you're left right or Center you
got to take this stuff with a certain
level of moral seriousness for you even
be taken seriously as a moral human
being the other blithe attitude toward
abortion is utterly astonishing the
Michelle wolf celebrate your abortion
fire off fireworks this is what makes us
free if your freedom is the killing of
none born human being and celebrating it
and fist pumping it while you do it
making fun of people who are depressed
and upset about doing it even if they're
doing it I mean what under what utter
callousness truly amazing
ok time for one more thing that I hate
so the I used to do something on the
show called deconstructing the culture
we may bring it back at some point but
basically this is an episode of
deconstructing the closure where we take
a piece of culture that people are
examining and taking a look at and and
we talk about how important it is and
why it affects your kids and affects you
and so Taylor Swift obviously one most
popular artists in America and as her
songs get worse she gets more woke now I
don't know which precedes the other I
don't know whether her talents has has
abandoned her and now she's relying on
woken us in order to force her forward
or maybe she's just got woke because she
had had enough of being insulted for not
being woken up and so she decided to get
overtly political
and then her song started to be crap by
the way I think there is a I think there
is something to this I think the more
avert Lipa litical artists get I think
the worse their art tends to be because
the art comes now second to the politics
this is true in movies ok it's true but
it's true for conservative as well as
liberal films by the way if there's a
conservative movie where the chief goal
of the movie is to foist conservative
politics on you it's usually not a good
movie if the chief goal is to entertain
you and then it happens to embed
conservative politics it can be very
good the same thing is true of leftist
politics I've seen a lot of good movies
with leftist politics where the politics
were not at the heart of the story but
if you have a story that is built on
leftist politics then very often it's
just not very good the same thing
happens to be true of Taylor Swift every
song she releases now is pop star never
stop never stopping her trying to get
woke and to do it publicly for the
plaudits of the Twitterati right now she
it's not enough for her to be a very
rich artist and very famous artists and
very popular artists just mean important
artists just to use her voice guys just
to use her voice and so she came out
with that ridiculous song last year in
which
she was like yeah gay people it was like
okay you're like 30 years late on this
lady you are really late on this and gay
marriage was legalized in auberge fell
in 2013 you're like half a decade late
on this it was exactly the case from
from pop star never stop never stopping
where the artists trying to get woke
cuts ate a gay marriage music video
after it's been legal for several years
in which he also and says he's not gay
okay so Taylor Swift has been doing that
well now she has a new video and this
new video is about feminism feminism so
what does feminism really about it's not
about female empowerment it's not about
things that make females unique and cool
which they are it's about why women are
victimized by men why men have it so
great and it's called the man in this
video Taylor Swift who directed produced
wrote directed produced liked this is
the very end of her videos just for
talking about how she did everything cuz
she's so empowered yeah you're worth
like two hundred million dollars lady
like I'm sure you're capable of doing a
lot of these things she she dresses up
as a man and then the basic suggestion
of this music video is that her life
would be better if she were man now let
me explain a very simple truth if Taylor
Swift for a ma'am
she'd be homeless and living down by the
river okay the reality is there are lots
of men who write songs like Taylor Swift
and none of them are nearly as popular
as Taylor Swift because there is
something to the idea of a sexy woman
singing songs to you this is how she
made her career and for those who don't
believe this is the case let me ask you
why you were celebrating Jennifer Lopez
strip dancing on a pole it turns out
that human beings like to look at pretty
people and pretty people doing things is
a thing that human beings like to look
at so if Taylor Swift had been 400
pounds she would not be famous if Taylor
Swift had looked like she does in this
video like a man she would not be famous
Taylor Swift has of course again this is
not a rip on her as she's a simple fact
the fact that she is a very beautiful
human being obviously has to do to a
certain extent with her success but her
suggestion is that if she were a man her
life would be better in some way all she
has received is plaudits from the
critics for her woke nests all she has
received for her entire career is
basically unending praise
show me the hardship the Taylor Swift
has experienced other than some people
being mean to her on Twitter poor baby
but here she is cutting a video about
how her life would be so much better if
she were a man
I would be complex I would be cool
I'd say I played the field before I
found someone to commit to and that
would be okay for me to do every
conquest I had made would make me more
of a boss to you okay pause it for a
second okay so this critique that she's
making that males are treated with with
sort of reverence for conquests and all
of this I actually sort of agree with
this critique ok this critique is
actually conservative critique of
quote-unquote liberated sexual
revolution America I kind of agree with
it the problem is that her conclusion is
that she should be allowed to do the
same stuff that men should do not that
men should stop acting like pigs this is
my big critique of large parts of the
feminist movement is that they critique
men for being pigs and then they're like
and so we should also be pigs and said
well how about like you should just need
to mentioned be pigs like I'm on board
with that one well this is why it's so
hilarious to me to watch the entire left
come around to me - right like I've been
on the me - bandwagon since before there
was a me - men should never treat women
this way why is this suddenly a shock to
you okay so the critique here is fine
the problem is that the conclusion that
you then proceeds to draw is that she
should be able to act like a man and
then be treated like a man as opposed to
men should stop acting like jackasses
hey here here is more of this idiotic
song what's that like
running started
okay she's sitting there with her with
her legs spread she's man spreading and
smoking on the sublight which by the way
is illegal in New York and okay let's
pause it there now this is where it gets
really stupid okay this is where she
leaves the realm of reality and just
gets into stupid land so she says I'd be
a fearless leader I'd be an alpha type
when everyone believes yeah what's that
like literally the entire media worships
at the altar of Taylor Swift and calls
her a fearless leader in an alpha type
literally everyone except for me
apparently I'll get all sorts of crap
for pointing this out but it happens to
be the truth she says I'm so sick of
running as fast as I can wondering if
I'd get there quicker if I was a man
okay physically you would because men
run faster than women just as a typical
rule on average but if we're talking
about like figuratively which is what
you're talking about that you're sick of
running as fast as you can because if
you'd get there quicker if you were a
man if you were a man you wouldn't be
famous
you wouldn't be rich what the hell are
you talking about
she's so she's so she's behind the
eight-ball guys Taylor Swift has been
behind the eight-ball her entire
unbelievably rich and wealthy life she's
been behind the 8-ball guys and you male
songwriters out there lagging and
obscurity because you're not an
attractive woman who can attract cameras
to you let me just tell you you have the
advantage she is not privileged you are
privileged the whiny victimhood from a
woman worth hundreds of millions of
dollars is just like it's unbelievable
it's it's just it's incredible and
she'll be celebrated for this because of
course she is she is intersectional in
the extreme and then the video is her
unzipping and peeing on the wall of the
13th Street Station by the way if a dude
in a Wall Street business suit started
peeing on the wall of a New York subway
station you know how fast that person be
arrested yeah that just insane
okay then the lyrics continue they'd say
I hustle put in the work
they wouldn't shake their heads in
question how much of this I deserve
focus Brotherhood good I'll be separated
from my good ideas and power moves
[Music]
okay so again the insane stupidity of
this is just incredible
she says they say a hustle put in the
work they wouldn't shake their heads in
question how much of this I deserve
last I checked there's an entire
Democratic race being run on the basis
that if you earn a million dollars who
didn't deserve it Michael Bloomberg is
being ripped as undeserving is he a lady
hey every single person who earns in
this country and is not a wild woke
leftist is considered to have not earned
their money by by Taylor Swift and her
people I mean by people like Taylor
Swift of the left and then in this video
it shows it shows her as a man picking
up a child world's greatest dad and all
of this you're celebrating for being a
great dad yes you should be celebrated
for being a great dad what is a problem
with this I'm confused why is that bad
now that women celebrate men who are
great dads that seems like a good thing
to do again which critique does she want
because if she wants to critique men for
being pigs she can't then say that she
should be treated well for being pigs
which is which is it seriously if you
have to decide is being a pig bad or is
being a pig good if being a pig is good
and what you should be complaining about
is that women aren't being pigs enough
and that you wish that you could be a
pig more okay but if the complaint is
that men are pigs then the complaint
should be the men are pigs
it's it what's it like to brag about
raking in dollars and getting
and models is one of the lyrics and it's
all good if you're bad and it's all and
it's okay if you're mad again I'm where
when has she been victimized ever she's
a victim she's a victim I fail okay this
is one of my favorite parts of the video
chose an old man marrying a young lady
who shows off like a big ring and then
in this video that woman ends up being
abused by the old man it's not that the
woman freely consented to enter a
loveless marriage for the money right it
is that the man has somehow taken
advantage of the woman is humiliating
her and that she she she volunteered in
okay she literally shows off in the
video this giant ring that she got for
marrying an old
I but all the blame is on the guy for
marrying the young woman last I checked
she had to consent to the marriage the
whole thing is just ridiculous
yeah but guys Taylor Swift is super
empowered she's super duper empowered in
every way and now I feel like she's woke
because she's proclaimed herself a
victim and if she proclaims herself a
victim then she is a victim and now
she'll get to show the video of me
talking about her stupid-ass video
she'll get to she'll get to show the
video of this in claim that I'm
victimizing her for criticizing her when
she is worth more money than God is more
successful in the public sphere than
presumably somebody like me will ever be
all because I'm a man hey guess what
Taylor you're not a victim you're not a
victim you're the greatest beneficiary
of a free American society that treats
women pretty damned well historically
speaking okay we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content by the way next Tuesday March
3rd join me the god-king Jeremy boring
Andrew Klavan to Michel moles on daily
wire backstage when we watch the results
from Super Tuesday roll in and in and
it's gonna be a very long evening so be
there to help us get through it I mean
it's gonna be interminable for me I have
to hang out with these people in person
but you can join us and watch me suffer
go check us out next Tuesday on our
Super Tuesday coverage we have a
cavalcade of comedy stars Italy it'll be
great so go check it out over at Daly
we're calm and as I mentioned earlier
make sure to check out daily wire
tomorrow because we have a very special
SuperDuper Cooper scooper deal our
special leap year deal it's not gonna
get better than this in terms of
becoming a member so go check it out
tomorrow daily wire.com otherwise we'll
see you here next week I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
[Music]
you